شركه لوكيد مارتن الامريكيه هي واحده من
ابرز الشركات العامله في مجال الصناعات
الدفاعيه حول العالم كما انها ايضا تتمتع
بوجود قوي في منطقه الشرق الاوسط على مدى
عقود
[موسيقى]
ساهمت شركه لوكيد مارتن الامريكيه عبر
حلولها الدفاعيه في مساعده المنطقه على
مجابهه الكثير من التحديات الامنيه هذه
التحديات طبعا التي تزداد تعقيدا يوما تلو
الاخر حول هذه الحلول الدفاعيه التي
تقدمها الشركه وكذلك عن مدى كفاءتها وايضا
مستقبل في منطقه الشرق الاوسط معنى هنا في
الاستوديو الجنرال جوني الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه لوكيد مارتن الامريكيه في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط اولا جنرال اهلا بك معنا في
عسكريتاريا دعني ابدا بعد كل هذه السنوات
من وجود لوكيد مارتن في الشرق الاوسط كيف
تقيم الحلول الدفاعيه التي قدمتها الشركه
لدول هذه المنطقه السلام عليكم
في برنامجكم كما تعرفون فان لوك هيد مارتن
موجوده في المنطقه منذ اكثر من 50 عاما
وعالميا نوفر لاكثر من مئه دوله والدول
التي تشتري المنتجات من لوك هيد مارتن لا
تحصل على افضل المنتجات في العالم فحسب بل
تصبح جزءا من عائله امم تشارك نفس
المنتجات وبالتالي بامكانها العمل معها
بشكل متوافق مما يوفر خيارات سياسيه لقاده
تلك الدول لتشكيل التحالفات العسكريه مع
الدول الاخرى ذات التوجهات المتشابهه كما
انها تستفيد من التقدم التكنولوجي الذي
توفره شركه لوك هيد في المجالات كافه
العام الماضي اعلنتم عن استثمار مليار
دولار في التصنيع العسكري داخل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ماذا عن خطتكم خلال هذا
العام خاصه بان السعوديه تشهد تحول كبير
في هذا المجال مجال الصناعات الدفاعيه
وباتت الان تسعى لتوطين هذه الصناعات وان
تكون جزء حتى من سلاسل الامداد العالميه
في هذا المجال
في معرض الدفاع العالمي 2022 اعلنت لوك
هيد عن اكثر من مليار دولار من
الاستثمارات في الصناعات السعوديه المحليه
وسنعمل عن قرب مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه كشريك استراتيجي لتلبيه اهداف
التوطين السعودي وهي الوصول الى نسبه 50%
من صناعه الدفاع بحلول 2030 هنا في
الامارات كذلك لديكم برنامج تدريبي مع
مركز الابتكار والحلول الامنيه هذا
البرنامج لمجموعه من المتدربين
الاماراتيين لتقديم روبوت يعمل بالذكاء
الاصطناعي لفحص محركات الطائرات كيف
تقيمون هذه التجربه بعدما قمتم بتدريب
مجموعه من الشباب الاماراتي
صفه مهمه في الشريك الاستراتيجي الجيد هي
ان علاقاتنا ليست قائمه على الصفقات فحسب
اي ليست قائمه على بيعنا للمنتجات وحصولنا
على الاموال نحن مهتمون بالاستثمار في
مستقبل الامارات ومن اهم السبل لتحقيق ذلك
هو عبر الاستثمار في الجيل الجديد من
الشباب الاماراتي الذين سيدفعون هذه
البلاد الى الامام باقتصاد قوي ونحن نفعل
ذلك من خلال استقطاب طلبه الجامعات
والمتدربين او حتى الخريجين الجدد للعمل
مع مهندسي وعلماء لوك هيد مارتن على حل
المشكلات الحقيقيه التي نواجهها اليوم مثل
التي ذكرتها فنحن نستقبل خريجي كليه
الهندسه من جامعه خليفه وكليات اخرى ممن
يعملون مع مهندسي لوك هيد مارتن واستخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي والروبوتات لحل المش
فيما يتعلق بالبحرين جنرال نيكلسون هي
بدات مؤخرا في استلام مقاتلات اف 16 بلوك
7 تي وكذلك الاردن وقعت عقد للحصول على
هذه المقاتله ايضا ما هو الفارق ما بين
طائره الاف سته عشر وطائره الاف 16 بلوك
17 وما الذي يميزها وكذلك هل هناك دول
اخرى في المنطقه تسعى لتحديث طرازاتها من
افسته عشر
كما تعرفون فان طائره اف 16 هي مشهوره جدا
حول العالم وتمتلكها اكثر من 25 دوله وقد
انتجنا اكثر من ثلاثه الاف طائره من هذا
الطراز وسلاح الجو الملكي البحريني كان
اول سلاح جوي في المنطقه ممن حصل عليها في
اواخر الثمانينيات ومطلع تسعينيات القرن
الماضي واليوم هم اول سلاح جوي يحصل على
احدث نسخه من الطائره وهي اف 16 بلوكس لقد
تشرفت بلقاء اللواء الركن طيار الشيخ حمد
بن عبد الله الخليفه قائد سلاح او الملكيه
البحريني في جرينفيلد بولايه صوت كارولينا
في الاسبوع الماضي الطائره تمثل التحسين
المستمر على النسخ السابقه وتحمل رادارات
متقدمه ومده خدمه تبلغ 12 الف ساعه ومحركا
متقدما سيدفعها الى مستويات اعلى جنرال
نيكلسون انت تعلم بانه الذكاء الاصطناعي
والليزر الان هم من احدث واهم التقنيات في
مجال الصناعات الدفاعيه والكثير من الدول
والشركات باتت تعول عليهم في هذه المرحله
لكن من خلال تجربتكم في لوكيد مارتن هل
تعتقد باننا سنرى تقدم في هذا المجال على
المستقبل القريب ام ان هذه التكنولوجيا
المتعلقه سواء بالذكاء الاصطناعي او حتى
بالاسلحه التي تعتمد على الليزر تحتاج
لسنوات او ربما لعقود لتطويرها وتصبح اكثر
كفاءه وفعاليه ميدانيه
وهذا سؤال وجيه يا اسامه وكما قلت
فالانضمام الى عائله لوك هيد يمكنهم من
الحصول على هذه التكنولوجيا تعمل حاليا
على اسلحه الطاقه الموجهه بالليزر للجيش
الامريكي وهذه تشمل الليزر الموجهه من
الفضاء الى الموجه من السفن والقواعد
البريه الثابته والمتحركه على المركبات
ونحن الان في المراحل النهائيه من تطوير
ليزر متحرك للجيش الامريكي بامكانه التنقل
مع وحداته واستخدامه ضد اسراب المسيرات
وما شابه فبينما تحصل هذه التكنولوجيا على
الموافقه في الولايات المتحده ستبحث
الحكومه الامريكيه عن امكانيه تزويد
حلفائنا بهذه التكنولوجيا
بالتاكيد انت يعني يعني هنا في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط منذ سنوات وتعلم جيدا
التغيرات الجيو السياسيه التي تشهدها
المنطقه في هذه المرحله الكثير من الدول
الان يعني باتت اكثر تعاونا مع دول منطقه
الشرق الاوسط فيما يتعلق بالصناعات
الدفاعيه او حتى فيما يتعلق بالتصدير
منتجاتها الدفاعيه لدول هذه المنطقه لكن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كانت دائما
هناك شكوى بان الحكومه الامريكيه تضع
الكثير من العوائق انتم كشركات عامله في
هذا المجال وكالكيد مارتن واحده من كبرى
الشركات العامله في هذا المجال على مستوى
العالم هل تتواصلون مع الحكومه الامريكيه
لشرح هذا الامر ولشرح انه هذه العوائق
التي تضعها الحكومه الامريكيه يؤثر على
حتى طريقه عمل الشركه
نعم نحن نعبر عن ذلك مع الحكومه الاميركيه
هذا السؤال مهم في المنافسه العالميه
تتزايد وكذلك خطر النزاع العالمي ايضا كما
نرى الازمه المستمره بين روسيا واوكرانيا
والتوترات بين الصين وتايوان ضد عدد من
الدول نجمت عن استخدام الوكلاء ما تسبب في
هجمات ضد عدد من الدول فللاسف العالم ليس
امنا هذه الايام ونحن ندرك ان التكنولوجيا
الامريكيه ضروريه من اجل مساعده اصدقائنا
وحلفائنا على الدفاع عن انفسهم لا شك ان
جلوس رؤساء الدول والتفاوض على صفقه سيسهل
الامور ولكن نظامنا يختلف عن ذلك النظام
لدينا يسمى نظام المبيعات العسكريه
الاجنبيه صمم لحمايه التكنولوجيا
الاميركيه وهناك خطوات اضافيه تتطلب
موافقه الحكومه واختار مجلس الشيوخ ولكن
حالما يتم ذلك فالفائده هي امكانيه توفير
افضل تكنولوجيا في العالم لاصدقائنا
وشركائنا في المنطقه